[Musique]
pour commencer au lendemain de
tchernobyl et des épinards radioactifs
voici des stages de survie qui nous
serait très utile si notre planète
devenait subitement celle des singes ça
se passe dans le sud de la france
c'est payant donc des volontaires et
c'est volontaire curieusement veulent
qu'un chef on veut h f
on veut un chef veulent qu'un chef même
si le dernier les avait conduits au
désastre qui les amène aujourd'hui à
s'entraîner à survivre
tout prêt à porter de nuages radioactifs
c'est un réacteur nucléaire qui
explosent ou bien les entrailles de la
terre qui se réveille ou encore un
séisme qui engloutit une ville
quand l'homme du xxème siècle joue à
l'atome et qu'il se retrouve tchernobyl
et alors ce qui n'était qu'une terrible
menace presque un fantasme devient
réalité
du coup on ne sait plus très bien s'il
faut sourire de tous ceux qui écoutent
médusés les prophètes du malheur
persuadé qu'un cataclysme naturel ou
technologie guette la planète
c'est par centaines qu'ils ont décidé de
se préparer
[Musique]
le soir du grand soir ils veulent
survivre
[Musique]
à
christian vincent serge michel et les
autres sont français ils se sont donné
huit jours pour s'initier aux techniques
de survie dans les cévennes méridionales
ils sont étudiants infirmières chômeurs
électronicien mêmes gendarmes en
retraite âgé profession peu de chose les
rassemble
si ce n'est peut-être la crainte sourde
d'une catastrophe irrémédiable pour 2500
francs par semaine les candidats à la
survie recherche aussi le grand frisson
et le zeste d' aventure qui manque à
leur vie sakodo matériel minimum par les
sentiers cévenol ils tenteront de croire
qu'ils sont de vrais survivants oublions
que leur itinéraire a été soigneusement
balisé par les instructeurs du stage des
militaires de carrière en permission
d'accord capacité de prendre une
décision
on prend une décision
le chef pour la décision et aux mains il
faut que le chef servent de référence
par son comportement par son attitude
par son vocabulaire
par ces paroles il devra considérer les
membres du groupe 1 par an en fonction
de leur personnalité
ensemble qu'on le pire est arrivé pour
survivre il faut se déplacer s'alimenter
et s'abriter mais en fait la survie cela
se passe dans la tête et par dessus tout
dans l'organisation d'une bonne relation
de groupe
[Applaudissements]
fini les balades de santé après un jour
ou deux il faut passer aux choses
sérieuses franchir une paroi rocheuse
n'est pas une mince affaire et nous
survivants ne sont pas au bout de leurs
peines voilà le pied droit bien coincé
un peu plus haut un tout petit peu fait
gagner
[Applaudissements]
collecte rationnelle du bois technique
du feu il faut réapprendre les gestes
d'autrefois mais les instructeurs ont eu
pitié leur pas à temps sur place de
superbes côtelettes qui dispensent
exceptionnellement de la recherche
combien hasardeuse de plantes
comestibles souvent impossibles à
identifier
selon vous il ya vraiment un danger
quelque chose qui pourrait vous mettre
dans une situation précaire
je pense que la survie on la vit un peu
tous les jours dans le milieu urbain et
finalement je pense qu'on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une catastrophe naturelle est
peut-être plus arriver à lapsus là
ah on y voit à peine le temps de
souffler et pas du tout celui de digérer
surprise on va franchir la rivière sur
une corde tendue 20 mètres au dessus du
rabbin
trop tard pour faire machine arrière il
faut laisser les états d'âme au
vestiaire et pendant qu'on se balance au
dessus du vide jambes de l'aisne et plus
raffolez sur la berge
les questions fusent que faire de ceux
qui refusent de passer
peut-on vraiment se résoudre à les
abandonner
[Applaudissements]
construire un radeau de fortune à l'aide
d'une bâche rempli paille ce peut être
une solution pour les moins téméraires
à condition bien sûr de disposer d'un
tel matériel et aussi de tenir compte de
sa précarité
après deux traversée mouvementée
l'embarcation peut couler corps et bien
le dilemme ne reste entier qui
embarquent et la vérité vous semble peut
être cruel mais ce ne sont pas forcément
les femmes et les enfants d'abord
[Applaudissements]
acheter là c'est par d'autres difficile
aux grosses chaleurs mais en ce qui vous
concerne vous êtes un vieil habitué de
la survie de la survie oui parce que
j'ai 46 ans je suis officier de réserve
bref tu es parachutistes gibier j'ai
chassé en guyane nord canada on va vous
avez gardé une espèce de fascination
militaire là je vous retourne la
question il ya que la veste parce que
elle est très pratique
sinon le reste est immense il vous juger
qu'il y à une urgence aujourd'hui oui je
peux vous dire qu'en tant que affecté
défense à la sécurité civile de
montpellier
je peux vous dire que les militaires
bien régler les problèmes de survie et
d'abris par rapport à éventuellement aux
fêtes nucléaire alors que l'on a fait
l'impasse sur les civils et que ça pose
problème maintenant est qu'une réflexion
est entreprise à ce sujet est vantée par
les kilomètres et les épreuves les
apprentis survivants s'installe enfin
pour la nuit
on improvise une base les gestes se
répète allumez le feu taille et les
brochettes bricoler des gamelles petit à
petit le métier entre pourtant il faut
encore surmonter l'épreuve
ce soir on assassine manifestement que
voulait tout y est et qui voulaient des
possibles à calmer la bête on va calmer
l'animal
on va là sommet et on va le signer
d'accord je vais tout simplement lui
faire le coup du lapin et derrière les
oreilles
il va être assommés et on pourra opérer
son problème voilà je lui prends la 40e'
très rapidement et voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà un dernier espace c'est terminé tu
veux pas c'est un petit peu difficile à
regarder mais c'est un geste naturel
quand on a quand on a faim gâteront jo
quand on veut manger
j'accepte de survie de toute façon
[Musique]
jamais pu être végétarienne enclin à son
pour te rassurer moi je fais ça sans
passion pour moi je fais ça c'est un
geste naturel pour manger pour assouvir
ma faim et ça va pas plus avec jour les
cauchemars nocturnes se dissipe enfin
sous l'autorité de jean marc le chef que
la bande s'est choisi la veille
le groupe part à la recherche d'un
nouveau camp de base seulement ils ne
savent pas tout enfin pas encore
[Applaudissements]
de votre survie je vais vous laisser on
va partir lenari chantal les deux et on
vous laisse ici jusqu'à demain matin
aussi tous les avis divergent on fait il
refait le point sans trouver d'accord
ici il faut voir ce qui ce chemin de
dessin normalement de choix michel
l'adessa et on va fait pas trop de
panique
la situation semble correct c'est du
tout la surprise qui nous laisse coi
à ce moment j'étais pas la destination
il souffre à vous la connaissez vous non
pas des six nations
bon donc on va se mettre près d'un point
d'eau où on va essayer de retrouver cet
endroit où être plus calme et de
s'organiser
les clans se forment le leader vert pied
un mini coup d'état se prépare vous ne
savez pas écouté on vous dit on vous dit
les le ravitaillement ne vient pas et
s'il ne vient jamais vous croyez qu
actuellement vous allez vous nourrir de
quatre frères bonie ferquois un stage de
survivre de khouribga suis venu faire un
sens je survis bon hiver grâce à visiter
ben non je ne vous fais pas confiance
vous êtes parti deux fois là bas une
fois ici vous êtes dispersez vous êtes
descendus vous êtes remonté et je
n'accepte pas l'idée première est la
recherche d'un point d'eau n'est ce pas
non gsm koné va tanguer entre lui-même
le directeur péter moi même d'être
fatigué mais ça va en valais c'est dû
rendre souple ces histoires des chefs
rachète on va se reposer
on va réfléchir ça va c'est l'os je suis
d'accord on vient juste d'arriver ici et
voilà
j'aimerais surtout dans l'état d'esprit
dans l'état où je suis j'aimerais qu'on
on assouplit c'est un peu attention
c'est le voit la tension ne voulait pas
mais on cherche on est tous c'est comme
ça on n'écoute pas les chefs
non c'est pas qu'on n'écoute pas la
bombe on l'argent non juste minutes on
est dans une état d'esprit en ce moment
une fois que c'est décidé comme ça le
chef si des fois ils supplient les
autres doivent encore plus se plier pour
le soutenir
mais si l on voit quelqu'un de rigide
devant nous à la limite moi alors à
partir de maintenant je refuse de jouer
le rôle de chef
vous prenez en compte toute façon je ne
suis plus là pas de star à moins que
vous changer d'idée intrus ne suis plus
sûr de faire partie de votre équipe
merci bon moi je prend en charge le
groupe tu vois là c'est tout on se
débrouillera pour aller au point d'eau
et la kippa loi et puis voilà tabur à la
base là bas marché des jours entiers
franchir des torrents escalader des pics
endurer la faim la soif et la fatigue
tout cela est possible le vrai piège de
la survie c'est le jeu des pouvoirs
le combat des chefs ce soir là le
troupeau égaré est redescendu vers la
civilisation ni honteux me soulager en
marchant bien dans les pas de leur guide
il avait survécu mais pas leurs
illusions
[Musique]